you
hi I would like to introduce our open
platform open source platform called are
open pi this is the landing page of the
platform you can see that right now open
time managed more than 200 GPUs on your
GPU VMs and from this page you can see a
set of jobs running on top of pi and we
can input a certain keyword to find
those jobs of interest for example in
this case I would like to find all the
jobs in the running States you can see
that right now there are more than 70
jobs in running stage and I can also
click one of the job to see the overall
information of the job for example this
job we use for GPUs and they export they
use one container for GPUs and with two
ports available and also we can see the
job configuration of this job and we can
copy those job configuration into a
local fire and use this configuration to
submit a job again so you can easily
reproduce this job on a cluster
we can also provide some information for
you to remotely log into this running
job to do remote debug also we use this
hardware page to monitor the overall GPU
CPU essential hardware resource usage
for this particular job
and open pine support of the concept
called a virtual cluster where multiple
teams can share a physical cluster with
different virtual clusters for example
in this cluster we have three virtual
clusters with different hardware
capacity configured and we also provide
some monitoring tools to show the
healthiness of different PI components
for example in this case all the
components shown in green are me means
the spy service are in healthy state we
also provide the user management you can
add new users and assign the user
different access permission to different
virtual clusters we also if you are
interested in PI please visit our github
website and we have a detailed document
to tell you to introduce how do you how
to deploy and operate and how to use
open pipe thank you
you